you said communism can't work because
jeans will openly or secretly work at
least partly for themselves would it
work in a nation of clones maybe with
different clone types for each function
like ants yes let me okay so that was
your answer I actually had just an aside
so ants aren't clones but they are
mostly female workers who if they share
both a mother and father are three
quarters related to each other the
sisters are which is more closely
related to each other than they are to
either their mother or would be
daughters and so they're invested in
protecting their queen their mothers so
that they can get more sisters at a
purely genetic level they win more when
they get more full sisters than they do
by breaking out on their own and
producing kids of their own and so you
end up with a youth social society which
is quite close-knit and has very little
reason for competition within it
although obviously competition does
happen so there are no ant clone
societies there are for instance well
like nomads offer us the whiptail
lizards in the Sonoran Desert go
parthenogenetic and they have you know
totally they're still not clones they're
they're actually parthenogenetic so
there are a hundred percent each kid
each daughter is a hundred percent
related to its mother but they self they
don't clone and so you lose genetic
variability with each reproductive event
but in each of the cases of the
parthenogenetic species there's some
place to borrow diversity from so even
down that road we're not going to find
with the right tails the right model
right lip tails and a FIDs and all the
others but anyway the thing you're
looking for the answer is a simple yes
right the body is communist that's what
it is it's communist because all the
cells are clones and it works and
communism can work hey isn't that good
news you know what you need to make
communism work brutality you need to
reorganize people's motivations by
threatening them if they act according
to their individuality which is why
communism is so frightening and you need
to keep up the brutality day-in day-out
forever or you never end or you need
to build it into people's developmental
environment so that they can't think for
themselves you turn them into sound like
cultural zombies so anyway it's a very
bad idea and that doesn't mean it can't
be made to function I mean and this is
some it's just it's very clear the fact
is for life to be worth living the human
has to be liberated to discover what is
good it does not mean that everybody
uses their Liberty well they don't most
people squander it but having Liberty is
the gift that we should be trying to
give to other human beings and a
communism wrecks it because it requires
brutality in order to overcome the
individuality that would cause the game
theory to break down that's a very
dangerous situation so it is not a
glorious solution to any problem
[Music]